un lago cerca del círculo ártico se
cubre con una capa de hielo de 2 metros
de grosor durante los meses de invierno
cuando llega la primavera el aire
caliente derrite el hielo gradualmente
provocando que su grosor disminuya a
tasa constante después de tres semanas
después de tres semanas la capa de hielo
tiene solo 1.25 metros de grosor dice
sea sdt el grosor de la capa de hielo s
medido en metros como función del tiempo
t medido en semanas escribe la fórmula
de la función muy bien entonces
esencialmente tenemos que dar una
expresión adecuada para la función s que
es el grosor en términos del tiempo
verdad y hasta ahora lo único que
sabemos es que cuando inicia la
primavera podemos decir que es digamos
en la semana 0 o al tiempo inicial éste
tiene
el grosor es de 2 metros eso es esta
esta información que tenemos aquí arriba
por otro lado sabemos que después de
tres semanas eso sería el grosor después
de tres semanas es igual a 1.25 muy bien
esta es la información que tenemos otra
forma de verlo por ejemplo sería
poniendo una tablita poniendo una
tablita donde tengamos el tiempo en
semanas y ese el grosor en metros
entonces por ejemplo a la semana cero el
grosor es de dos metros mientras que a
la semana tres el grosor es de 1.25
verdad entonces por ejemplo qué pasa con
el tiempo cuál es nuestro cambio en el
tiempo y esencialmente nuestro cambio en
el tiempo extra es verdad vamos de cero
semanas a tres semanas entonces nuestro
cambio en el tiempo es tres por otro
lado nuestro cambio
el grosor es ir de 2 a 1.25 entonces
disminuimos 0.75 muy bien entonces con
esto podríamos intentar calcular la tasa
de cambio de nuestra función y eso es
importante porque nos dice que el grosor
disminuye a tasa constante es decir en
realidad no importa si nos tomamos el
tiempo 0 y el tiempo 3 pudimos habernos
tomado la semana 1 y la semana 2 o
quizás la semana 1.5 y la semana 4 en
realidad no importa la tasa de cambio
debe ser exactamente la misma así que
nuestra tasa de cambio va a ser
constante a lo largo de toda la función
verdad como calculamos la tasa de cambio
bien bueno esto ya lo hemos visto es
nuestro cambio en el grosor dividido
entre el cambio en el tiempo verdad y el
cambio en el grosor es de menos 0.75
metros mientras que el cambio en el
tiempo
tres semanas tres semanas ahora bien
esto es algo muy fácil de resolver
verdad nosotros sabemos que 75 lo
podemos dividir entre 3 y nos da 25 pero
bueno tiene un punto decimal y tiene un
signo menos así que tendremos menos 0.25
metros por semana
semana muy bien ahí lo tenemos la tasa
de cambio desde menos 0.25 metros por
semana y en realidad no importa de qué
puntos esto de qué momentos de que
semanas estemos hablando verdad es la
misma en todo momento así que ya que
tenemos la tasa de cambio constante que
es menos 0.25 metros por semana como
usamos esta información para construir
una función que caracteriza a ese que es
el grosor y nosotros sabemos que debe
ser lineal pues la tasa de cambio es
constante verdad recordemos que las
funciones lineales son esas que se ven
de la forma por ejemplo de igual a mx +
b donde x es nuestra variable
independiente m es la pendiente y b es
la ordenada al origen por supuesto aquí
no tenemos ya nosotros tenemos ese como
función del tiempo entonces este es
nuestra variable independiente y me
sigue siendo nuestra pendiente o nuestra
tasa de cambio que es la variable
independiente
sigue siendo la ordenada al origen muy
bien y calcular la ordenada al origen es
muy fácil verdad eso simplemente surge
de evaluar s en 0 verdad sí sí te es 0
entonces este término no aparece y sólo
nos queda b pero por otro lado nosotros
ya sabíamos cuánto era el grosor en la
semana 0 y es 2 así que ve es igual a 2
ahora bien m es la pendiente pero la
pendiente de la recta es igual a la tasa
de cambio que ya lo hemos calculado
así que nuestra pendiente m es igual a
menos 0.25 muy bien así que también m es
la pendiente que hay entre estos dos
puntos verdad el punto 0 2 y el punto
3,1 punto 25 en el plano t s muy bien
así que con esto ya podemos escribir
quién es la función s dt s dt es igual a
m verdad que en este caso es menos 0.25
por t que es nuestra variable
independiente más b que en este caso es
2 verdad y quizás otra forma de ver esta
función sería de la siguiente forma 2
menos 0.25 de iu a mi cerebro le gusta
mucho más ver la función ex expresada de
esta forma porque nos indica con cuánto
iniciamos de grosor que en este caso es
2 y eso es cuando te vale 0 y a medida
que avanza el tiempo o avanzan las
semanas nos dice que a 2 hay que
restarle un cuarto verdad por cada
semana es decir por ejemplo a la primera
semana a 2 le estaríamos restando 0.25 a
la segunda semana a 2 le estaríamos
restando dos veces 0.25 que es lo mismo
que 0.5 muy bien así
consecutiva podríamos ir determinando
cuál es el grosor a medida que las
semanas aumentan ahora bien para que
quede mucho más claro te invito a que
gràfiques esta función ideas que en
efecto la pendiente es menos 0.25 y que
coincide con la pendiente entre estos
dos puntos y que veas que la ordenada al
origen que en este caso es nuestro valor
de b es 2 es decir el lugar en donde
intersecta al eje vertical